so the media storm and the Twitter blitz
that ensued with the first sharknado
from having a father that was a
journalist and being exposed to that
industry what tips did you take away
from him or observe from him that helped
you handle that viral success
interesting I think growing up with the
journalist father and a very proper
British mother I don't know that they
actually prepared me for the specifics
of how I handled the explosion of
interest after sharknado but what they
did was they gave me a well-rounded and
worldly perception I was exposed to a
lot of different stuff as a kid not just
the little slice of life that I would
otherwise have grown up in my father was
also a professional wine critic so we
not only did we have our middle-class
life in New York City not only was I
exposed to you know ideas regarding the
world and politics and all that stuff
but we also traveled in in some social
circles well above our actual financial
standings because as a wine critic
you're you're sort of forced into the
upper echelons of society so I really
got to see how ever
how did nothing just the other half live
but how all the different halves lived
and I think just having sort of a
well-rounded perception helped keep me
from getting too overwhelmed during the
the attention blitz that followed the
release of sharknado and the other thing
really that I that I credit is simply
that I had spent 20 years trying to get
into this business if this had happened
if sharknado would have
and when I was in my mid-20s when I came
out here intending for something like
this to happen I'd probably be so
screwed up right now I'd probably be a
raging egomaniac but but years of being
humbled you know being beaten down sort
of banging my head against doors that
wouldn't open for me I think has helped
has helped me keep a level head during
all of this
that and the fact that things like this
just don't happen and and for this to
happen even once is an incredible
blessing and there sure as hell no way I
could expect it to ever happen again so
I had to take maximum advantage of it
when you get an opportunity you've got
to take it for all it's worth so if I
had just let this go to my head and I'd
gone off and become you know like a
Hollywood party person instead of
buckling down and doing every interview
I could and meeting taking every meeting
I could getting an agent making the most
of out of this professionally that I
could and trying to keep my trying to
keep my own my own sense of self in
check and intact was vitally crucial to
my perception of my future progress and
future happiness I'd been working to
become an overnight success for 20 years
and here was my opportunity so if I
screwed this up I just have to you know
blow my brains out or something
so I couldn't allow myself to be
overwhelmed or to get carried away and
mind you I've been a bit overwhelmed and
a bit carried away
but I've been able to temper that you
know and and sometimes doing a lot of
press that that whole first week after
sharknado came out it's just a blur that
that night was the most surreal
experience of my life and then the next
morning when I started getting calls for
interviews and and two days later I was
shooting a segment for Good Morning
America I mean you know things like this
don't happen and so I've just tried to
enjoy it but at the same time friends
look at me and say why aren't you
partying why is it why aren't you
jumping for joy why aren't you just
going nuts and I am but it's on the
inside I'm trying to maintain some kind
of equilibrium because I know that I
have to make the most of this that I
possibly can if I want to do and be what
I always said I was going to do and be
you